hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well another form of
justice understood is particular justice
and as fairness or equality that
Aristotle discusses in nikka mcKane
ethics book five has to do with what we
call rectification this is often called
rectification justice which comes from
our our Latin it word rectus you know
which means right so rectification
literally means setting things right
restoring an order that has been or an
equilibrium that has been lost that has
been damaged that has been undone and
when we talk about justice in this sense
Aristotle doesn't think of it so much as
a quality of a person as more of a
quality of states of affairs so a judge
he says is called a rectifier because
he's a divider he actually sets things
right by by figuring out what the
proportions are and he takes the injured
party and he says okay you get some of
the offending party the the injuring
party you get some of their stuff to
make up for it
make it right so could this actually
have to do with the nature person
person's character yes it could
Aristotle doesn't spell this out but the
kind of person who would be prone to
when they do the wrong thing to make it
right or to at least think that other
people ought to do you know what's
required to make it right or perhaps
would find ways to make sure that that
would happen that would be a just person
in the sense of having justice as a
virtue likewise a person who was
typically making things unfair
unbalanced who enjoyed doing so who you
know messes around with other people
that to make things unfair big picture
somebody who just enjoys giving some
people more money and some other people
less money just to kind of get them you
know irritated with each other and
something that ODS that person would be
unjust in the full sense of having the
vise of injustice
Aristotle's not so concerned with that
he's more concerned with thinking about
things in terms of what he calls
voluntary and involuntary exchanges now
could this extend beyond just the kind
of exchanges Aristotle's talking about a
course as a matter of fact it could
apply to relationships it could apply to
previous distributions you know if there
was an unfair distribution you know
historically then that could be fixed
equal opportunity the the basic idea
behind equal opportunity programs was
that certain minorities have been had
been given the wrong sort of proportion
they weren't allowed the opportunities
that they should have been allowed and
that set them behind so we're gonna
rectify that by you know giving them
more opportunities in the press
and then hopefully at some point we can
actually say everybody's on the same
level playing field that's an example of
retro fitori justice that doesn't
actually fit into either one of these
because it has to do with the structure
of an entire society or at least
governmental institutions what Aristotle
talks about is voluntary and involuntary
exchanges voluntary exchanges would be
things like buying and selling entering
into contracts with people making loans
becoming a debtor those are all
voluntary a person decides to do them
and it doesn't mean that they
necessarily want to do it you know you
might have to take out a debt because
you actually here's a great example
there's nobody who really really in
their heart wants to post bail bond for
other people other than bail bonds but
because they're making money off of it
but people do it it's still voluntary
because they're choosing to do it on
some level and if you want to see what
Aristotle means about the voluntary and
involuntary I have a number of videos
discussing that some of them core counts
them some of them longer lecture videos
now when we get to the involuntary what
Aristotle is actually talking about is
criminality he says there's fraud and
there's force what would be examples of
fraud
well theft when you go in and you steal
somebody from somebody steal something
from somebody's house adultery this is
an interesting one stealing somebody
away we do say you know she stole you
know her husband or he stole his wife
right he stole the affection of another
there could be a lot of other examples
of that what about a force well assault
on another person is force rape is is
force threatening to use force against
another person would be
type of force Aristotle actually puts
Lander in there as well with fraud
somebody is doing something without
being noticed without you know they're
they're pretending to be doing something
other than they are and they get more
than their fair share in the process
what could the fair shares be property
maybe you know election fixing would be
a type of fraud getting getting an
office that you shouldn't have force
somebody actually uses violence to get
more than their fair share or get
somebody else more than their fair share
if I walk into the coach's office and I
say look I want my kid to play
basketball and the coach says well you
know your kid isn't very good he's gonna
be sitting on the bench the first year
and I pull out a gun and say he's not
gonna be sitting on the bench
somebody else's kid has to sit on the
bench in place of my kid I am taking
more than my fair share for my kid I'm
also in a certain sense committing
injustice in a second way by depriving
the jutt the the the coach of their
normal decision-making process and
taking that away from them so here's how
aristotle season in all of these cases
justice lies in between the loss to the
person who has been cheated wronged
harmed offended and the game that has
been you know taken or at least come to
the benefit of the other person in in
this relationship in this structure in
this perhaps social condition or
institution so what does justice mean
justice means setting things back in the
middle does that mean that you just give
back so somebody for example steals from
me do I just get back what they took
from me no it might actually mean
something on top of that as well you
know compensate me for my
my time in trouble that compensate me
for having to go to court to compensate
me for other damages that I feel that
I've suffered but in any case the the
suffering is alleviated Aristotle thinks
by swinging things back over this way
what you're doing is you're taking
something from the person who has now
too much giving it to the person who has
too little and thereby restoring justice
this gets more problematic and Aristotle
says yeah we got to be a bit
metaphorical about this when we talk
about say what is the person who
attacked me how do I how does the judge
set that right you know is putting them
in prison for example which is what we
tend to do it's putting them in prison
mind getting back what's owed to me
what's been taken from me many people
would say well not really I'd like to
you know punch him in the face myself or
I'd like him to feel what it is that I
felt this gets particularly problematic
when we get to crimes like say rape you
know or you know over here at fraud
adultery or cheating is it is it set
right by if you you know seduce my wife
I go and seduce your wife Ariston would
say that that's not really what he has
in mind
maybe there's ways in which one can
compensate in other ways you know the
same thing to go for missing an
opportunity that was that one was
deprived of because somebody else was
given it because they were the boss's
son or they knew somebody who knew
somebody who knew somebody or the person
who was making the decision at the time
was not really in their right mind when
they they made it setting it right for
some of these decisions may not mean
being given that position because now
this other person is in that position
and they can't just simply create a new
so it does get a little problematic but
the general principle is that justice
consists in setting things right in
restoring the balance between the loss
or the suffering and the gain or the
benefit to you know from from one party
to the other swinging at the from one
side to the other